on the pressure surrounding the
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi the Prime Minister has been
talking about his decision to get his
ethics advisor to invest in Mr sahabi
amid tax questions Rishi sank was
talking on a visit to a hospital in
northamptonshire that's listening
integrity and accountability is really
important to me and clearly in this case
there are questions that need answering
and that's why I've asked our
independent advisor to get to the bottom
of everything to investigate the matter
fully and establish all the facts and
provide advice to me on the dean
zahawi's compliance with the ministerial
code I'm pleased that Nadeem zahawi has
agreed with that approach and has agreed
to fully cooperate with that
investigation you can decide whether Mr
zahawi stays or goes why don't you ask
him to stand down
well I think it's important that we do
these things professionally that
integrity and accountability is really
important to me but it's also important
that we do these things properly and
that's why the independent advisor has
been asked to fully investigate this
matter and provide advice to me on the
dean zahawi's compliance with the
ministerial code and on the basis of
that we'll decide on the appropriate
next steps but Nadine zahari has agreed
to fully cooperate with that
investigation shouldn't he stand aside
from his party chairman role while this
investigation continues as is
long-standing practice he will continue
to to play the role that he does but it
is important that we answer these
questions we get to the bottom of things
establish the facts that's important to
me I think integrity and accountability
is Paramount in government and I want to
do these things professionally which is
why I've asked the independent advisor
to fully look at this matter and provide
advice to him but doesn't he owe the
public more of an explanation well these
things are dealt with by an independent
advisor who will fully investigate this
matter and provide advice to me as prime
minister on the dahim zahawi's
compliance with the ministerial code
that's the right approach it's the
professional approach and that's how
we'll restore integrity and
accountability into government overall
is by making sure that when situations
like this arise we deal with them
promptly we deal with them
professionally and that's what we're
doing in this case will you order some
sort of probe into the appointment of
Richard Sharp As BBC chairman and his
relationship to the former prime
minister
well this appointment was obviously made
by one of my predecessors before I
became prime minister and the
appointments process itself though for
appointing the BBC chairman is a
rigorous process it's independent there
is two two stages to it it's transparent
and published online and Mr Sharp's
appointment went through that full
process
should the BBC chairman Richard Sharp
himself have declared during this
process that he did have some
relationship with the Prime Minister
over the loan
should that have been declared by him
and so the appointments process for this
particular post is very rigorous it's
independent there are two stages to it
and it's all set out publicly and
transparently and all those processes
were followed in this case but this was
obviously an appointment that happened
before I was prime minister and made by
one of my predecessors are you happy for
him to continue as BBC chairman yeah I
said Mr Sharp went through two different
appointments processes which are
transparent and rigorous and have been
followed fully
will you apologize to the public for not
wearing a seatbelt last Thursday
yes I regret not wearing a seatbelt it
was a mistake and that's why I
apologized straight away
how can the public be reassured that you
as prime minister respect the laws of
the land which everyone has to follow of
course I do and in this instance I I
made a mistake which I regret deeply and
that's why I apologize straight away